Hello, welcome everybody. How is everybody doing today? This is going to be an
awesome listening and speaking class. I'm so glad that all of you are here. Welcome
everybody. See the screen. All right. Now? Yes. Okay. So remember, good
communication starts with good listening, being an active listener means showing
you're engaged. Sometimes we listen quickly for the main idea and that's our
fast and intuitive thinking and other times we need careful analytical
listening and that's when we really kind of pick things apart and try to
understand the deeper meaning of those things. So we need to practice both types
of listening to understand the superficial level of things in the meaning and
to understand (the) deeper analytical level of things. When you practice a lot, you get
the hang of it and you don't have to kind of deliberately seek to understand it
so much. You'll just understand and it will become more intuitive with time but
it's always good to analyze first. So we'll listen as the scenario is read
here. I want you to listen to it twice with different focuses and I'm trying to
show something that you might not understand. So don't feel bad if you don't. Okay.
All right. Okay, team. For the new project, I need everyone to synergize their
deliverables by COB Tuesday and ensure proactive stakeholder engagement. Make it
snappy. Did you understand? The main idea, but there are some new words
others are okay. Okay, so you have some experience which is great. You've got the
main idea that we need to work together to get something done but there might
be some things here that you don't understand. Which words are hard for you to
understand? So the words that I don't understand are
synergize and snappy. Okay, so to synergize something is basically to make
things in sync, right? When things are synchronized, they're synergized. They
work well together, right? So we need everybody to basically come together and
agree on what deliverables, what needs to be produced by Tuesday, and to make
it snappy is to do it quickly. Oh, okay. When you're talking.
You're using that word, right? Oh, make it snappy.
All right. So let's listen to a short scenario and imagine you're in this
this meeting. If you were to hear that in a meeting, what would you
do to interrupt to try to understand? If you had some sort of question, you have
the main idea, right? But you wouldn't probably want to listen to what comes next a
little bit. How would you ask for clarification?
Well, as you mentioned, everything is about listening. So I think I will wait the
person to end what that person is (going to say)? And if I don't understand, then I will go
and like, hey, I need clarification on this part of what I just say.
So you would wait for the person to finish saying what they want to say.* And that's because
you don't want to be rude or interrupt anyone when they're talking. Yes. Actually, I always
tried to wait because you need to know what the person is thinking and not just to think like
that's what you're saying. So it's good not to make assumptions. I agree. And it's great to wait
for those pauses in speech and conversation to know when we can ask for clarification.
Okay. So how do we interrupt politely? That's part of what we're talking about today.
Asking for clarity. They're useful phrases. Well, I would say, excuse me,
what's like, that would be a good example.
So I will say, excuse me, I just would like to know what you are trying to say when you are
talking about this contract or something like that. Okay. So I need more clarification on these
subjects. All right. It's very formal. I like that.
Yes, we need to... that's like our environment when we talk with we have our meetings.
We can make* jokes outside, you know, but then we are with the meeting where we need to try to be
a really like professional. You can be more casual outside of the meeting, but in the meeting
itself, it's time to be professional and formal. All right. So this language register is really
a bit formal and also intonation is important. You know, sounds rise and they fall too. So an
example would be sorry. Could you please repeat the part about COB or could you repeat the part
about making it snappy? What does that mean? All right. So now notice that we use could here and could
is considered more polite than can. So could is a little bit more formal and then can is a little
bit more casual, although you can use either one. Someone is not being disrespectful if they use can,
but if you want to show more formality, it's better to use could. Here's another example.
This time I would like for you to try to raise the intonation at the end. So is that right?
All right. Is that right? Can you, can you read this part here?
If I understand correctly, you're asking us to, is that right?
Is that right? Yeah. And here's another example. We're working a lot. Is that right?
We have to come in this weekend. Is that right? All right. How about this one? Can you read
this one for us? Could you please explain what you mean by snappy?
Uh-huh. Very good. Hi, snappy. Well, snappy means it should be different.
Well, no, I think that's fine. We can use, for example, like the one you said COB because
there are some people* that don't know what COB means. You could just simply ask, could you
tell me what snappy means? I don't know this. It's a new word for me, you could say.
You know, I think sometimes we feel embarrassed when we don't know something.
And so we don't want to ask, we don't want to admit, but it's okay to clarify.
The whole purpose of communication and business is to understand and be understood.
And a key takeaway from this slide here is basically we use could to make polite requests.
You can use discourse markers like excuse me or if I understand correctly you're asking
or you're telling us that's right and then rephrasing what they say. Those are really great ways to
ask for clarification. All right. So go ahead, I'm sorry.
No, maybe before I didn't use to do that, but now like I feel more confident to ask for
the meaning of the word, to (know) what they're saying. So we know what they're exactly there trying
to communicate. Yeah... it only gets better with time.